s'amuse avec julien da rold il est
délégué syndical cfdt
3a sous traitants en aéronautique
[Musique]
bonjour julien da roth merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france c'est un des effets pervers de
cette crise sanitaire des salariés qui
avait été prié de prendre la porte de
sortie pendant le confinement finalement
sont rappelés n'est pas du tout dans les
mêmes conditions qu'avant
oui tout à fait bonjour c'est ce qu'on a
pu constater c'est bien les jours où on
s'aperçoit en fait que nos salariés
mais certains de nos salariés sont
rappelés pour des contrats de chantier
ou des contrats d'intérim alors qu'ils
occupent et des vous pour les mêmes
postes et qu'ils autres qu'ils occupent
et qu'ils occupaient le pop art amant en
cdi normal donc c'est bien des
fonctionnaires cdi dont qui ont ce cd
l'entreprise a mis un terme sur quel
motif pendant le confinement économique
aux cartes de l'emploi en fait ils ont
été licenciés avant au moins deux mois
de janvier donc il était dans leurs
congés de reclassement l'entreprise a
mis tout un dispositif en place pour
pouvoir au pouvoir les réembaucher
c'est à dire que c est un pays assez
atypique on est passé on est bon il y
avait plusieurs avenants fait à ce pse
est la dernière mesure en date c'était
donc de réembaucher les gens qui étaient
en congés de reclassement
là on a eu dernièrement des propositions
de réembauche pour ces personnes-là sont
sur 18 propositions de poste dans
l'entreprise 10 concernent des contrats
et contrats dits précaires concédé que
nous pas de chantier est et ce qu'on
dénonce également c'est que les contrats
là sont normalement très cadré par
d'autres branches de la métallurgie etc
et que l'employeur respecte pas l'accord
de branche qui existent en la matière on
précise d'ailleurs que ça touche
beaucoup l'aéronautique puisque vous y
travaillez vous même et des emplois
finalement qui sont qui sont qualifiés
est très spécifique
oui bah oui c'est des métiers et des
métiers techniques ont été annoncés la
technicité des métiers aéronautiques on
sait la compétence qu'on nous demande au
moment d'aller chercher aujourd'hui
toujours plus de toujours de toujours
être
être être plus plus fort mais de
s'adapter aussi aux réalités techniques
et aux demandes de nos clients
donc oui c'est des personnels qui ont
fait énormément d'efforts et également
sur des mobilités genre de choses
aujourd'hui on leur demande de reprendre
dans des conditions salariales et
conventionnelles - mois moins
intéressant que ce canal que ce qu'elle
avait notamment au niveau de la prime
d'ancienneté tu qu'ils ont tout perdu
pourquoi comment ce qu'on voit ce que
les entreprises justifient ces
conditions qui sont revus à la baisse
c'est ce que est ce que le profit n'est
pas au rendez vous ils justifient pas
vraiment en fait disent que c'est c'est
toujours savez c'est toujours à la
demande du client le client nous demande
une prestation sur tel sur tel le site
ou sur elle je suis sur telle activité
nous nous ce qu'on déplore cesser le
premier dimensionnement du pse chez nous
il parlait de 719 sentiment aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit que on est à 280 salariés
notifié de les sentiments et en plus on
les rappelle encore donc je pense qu'on
a approché à l'employeur est ce qu'on me
reproche encore c'est qu'il n'a pas
utilisé tous les dispositifs qu'ils
pouvaient qu'il pouvait utiliser mais
c'est le cas des sociétés que qu'ils
pratiquent aujourd'hui ce genre de
choses
très peu ont mis en place l'activité
partielle de longue durée très peu s'en
sont servis et donc aujourd'hui on a cet
effet de surdimensionnement des plans
ceux des plans de sauvegarde de l'emploi
qui qui qui paie qui pose problème
maintenant aux sous traitants pour venir
rechercher recherché de l'activité et
avoir de la main d'oeuvre qualifiée
ce que vous déplorez finalement c'est
qu'il ya pas eu de mesures de chômage
partiel comme c'est le cas notamment
pour la restauration
oui c'est ça c'est ça on a eu les
mesures les mesures de chômage partiel
de droit commun mais on n'a pas eu les
mesures de chômage partiel étendu comme
pouvait l'être l'activité partielle de
longue durée qui aurait permis d'avoir
une très longue période et de sécuriser
les contrats de travail
donc c'est évidemment c'est évidemment
dommageable de peut-être d'être sur ça
mais mais assez c'était le choix
l'employeur n'a poussé on n'a pas signé
le plan rouge ou une de ces raisons
notamment le plan a été annulé de façon
administrative c'est assez assez
chaotique quand même ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé chez nous c'est quand
même plein de rebondissements et ses cci
s'est malheureusement ça prouve une
mauvaise volonté mauvaise volonté du
côté du côté de nos employeurs pour pour
maintenir les emplois nous on est
convaincu que plus généralement et sans
le sens être complotistes mais que c'est
un un projet de filière de pouvoir de
pouvoir aussi équilibré équilibrer le
niveau des revenus et des salaires en
tout cas sûr sûr sûr le global de la
filière et que du coup on est dans un
vril dumping social général c'est
d'avoir pris prétexte la crise sanitaire
finalement pour revoir un peu justement
ces emplois à la baisse oui tout à fait
tout à fait y avez vous savez qu'on
parle de compétitivité de deux genres de
choses dans les entreprises généralement
on voit pas la compétitivité comme nous
on peut la voir en tant que salarié sur
la le niveau de production ou sur la
qualité on voit souvent la compétitivité
comme comme du côté employeurs sur sur
les salaires comment on peut faire pour
maintenir les masses salariales me
mettre à mon niveau
les contrats vont revenir
l'emploi l'emploi va revenir finalement
est ce que vous êtes positif pour
finalement essayer de renégocier ses
contrats
mais le problème c'est que les contrats
vont venir mais c'est qu'on a perdu
aujourd'hui des compétences les salariés
qui sont partis dans d'autres
entreprises qui sont partis qui ont été
licenciés qui ont changé complètement le
secteur d'activité ses compétences là on
les retrouve pas ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir aussi réformé énormément car sa
route
l'emploi évidemment le secteur
aéronautique un secteur qui crée
énormément d'emplois tant dans
l'économie de notre pays
mais il va falloir former dire que tout
ce qu'on a fait pendant 10-15 ans pour
former des salariés avec la compétence
il va falloir tout reprendre pour eux
sur le long terme on n'entend plus très
bien merci en tout cas merci julien da
rold de nous avoir livré votre
témoignage ce matin en direct sur arte
france
[Musique]